OF THE NHL
>> Brian: JOHN GIBSON'SUMBER OF
CHANCES FROM HIGH CAININGER
AREAS THAN LAST SEASON, THIS
JUST A LITTLE BIT OFF BUT LOOK
AT CARRICK, THAT'S H H THE
REFEREES, DOING HIS VERSION OF
POOLMAN HIS DEFENSIVE PARTNER
BANGED ALONG THE BLUE LINE, NOT
OUT OF THE ZONE TERRY ABLEAN GE.
LOOK THERE'S THE PASS T
HIATUS FROM THE BENCH.
>> Andy: IT'S HE'LL COVER
WITH NO REBOUND COMING NO,
RIGHT BACK WENT UP AND OVER THE.
>> Andy: I THINK IT DID.
LELE
GETZLAF CROSSES.
KIND OF BROKEN OF GOODING
HERE, JUST GETS A LITTLE PIECE
OF IT.
I THOUGHT THAT PUCK SHAW WHO'S O
PAL
>> L
CORNER.
PUCK SNARED AND THEN TURNED
OVER.
LETTIERI DOWN LOW.
GETZLAF TO
COUPLE OF
TERRY, BUT CHIPPED AWAY NINE
SECONDS LEFT, BAC TALKING -- SO
WHEN LETTIERI WAS JUST TEEING
OFF ON THAT CIRCLE. GO, HE GETS
IT RIGHT  EVERYTHING'S FINE NOW?
NOW GUILLAUME
BRISEBOIS WILL COME UP WITH IT.
>> Andy: THAT
DESLAURIERSR DESLAURIERS.
ON THE PUCK IS CARRICK, LEAFSNI
MINNESOTA.
SO HE'S A LITTLE BIT PERIOD,
1-1 THE SCORE.
DUCKS HAD A LEE FOR A GOOD
ON THE POWER PLAY.
>> Brian: PEN KILLERS EKMAN-LAR
>> SMART MOVE BY ME
BACKHAND OFF THE BOARDS TO
HIMSELF BUT WIDE OF THE NET.
ROBINSON TO THE FAR BOARDS ROLLD
UP TO PEARSON.
HE'LL LOB IT IN
THAT IS AN POOLMAN DROVE NIGHT E
DUCKS ZONE, QUICKLY WORKED
DICKINSON'S THIRD SHOP AT IT
WILL MOVE IT BACK
DUCKS' LEADING GOALAKELL AND MI
WILL TURN IT THE OTHER WAY,
PLAYED IT OFF THE BOARDS TO